hey guys Pete here this will be my dark
season 3 ending explain video I just
finished watching the series and I've
got to be honest at the end of episode 5
I was really confused and borderline
worried about whether or not I knew what
was going on
fortunately the ending turned out to be
pretty straightforward though and I
can't wait to talk about it real quick
though this is your spoiler warning if
you haven't finished watching the entire
dark series this video won't be for you
with that out of the way let's get into
it so at the end of episode 7 Adam is
basically all of us he thought he had it
figured out but it turns out he was
wrong his plan to wipe out the world
involve destroying alt Marta who was
carrying their unborn child and the god
particle and one go Adam believes their
child must be the origin of the knot
because it is the origin of the
time-traveller family tree he uses the
force of both apocalypses through the
portal to destroy her it's almost
comical as he closes his eyes and waits
there to cease to exist he holds them
close for a bit takes a breath and then
nope nothing he's still alive and his
face resembles what mine probably looked
like through most of the middle of this
season
Claudia then arrives to explain what
happened she tells Adam that Ava used
something called quantum entanglement
which is complicated but in this
situation what's important is that it
leads to the overlapping of different
realities she explains that time stands
still for a second during the apocalypse
which provides an opportunity for things
to proceed in two different directions
10 house from the 1970s gives us a
description of this using the thought
experiment of Schrodinger's cat in the
beginning of episode 7 Ava
exploits this by letting Marta say be
honest and bring him to their world in
one reality and having alt bartosh stop
Marta and bring her back in another this
creates the situation where yonus and
Marta are existing in two realities at
the same time and ensures their child
will be born in the one where bartosh
brings her back in that way Abel always
has an advantage over Adam
but all the advantage does is preserve
the loop everything continues as it was
claudia learned this as she was trying
to figure out a way to save her daughter
reginae who dies in both of their worlds
where he onus and Marta's son turns out
to be the thing that keeps the loop
continuing to happen Claudia's daughter
turns out to be the thing that is the
key to stopping it she explains that
both worlds Adams and Ava's should never
have existed they are the product of HG
tan house trying to save his family with
time travel in a third world the actual
origin world we've been talking about
prime world it turns out that neither of
those are the real world
Claudia figured out that things are
deterministic in the worlds we've seen
as far as the outcome things may develop
differently but no one can escape their
fate she's able to exploit that same
loophole of time standing still during
the apocalypse to come to Adam and tell
him what he needs to do he needs to send
yonis and Marta to the origin world so
that they can stop the event that led to
the creation of their worlds in the
first place Adam goes to the con walled
house in his world as the apocalypse is
happening Marta has already been shot
but since this is the reality where
yonus would run into the basement
there's no alt Marta coming to save him
he then explains that there is a way
that yonas can stop himself from
becoming Adam
yonis has to go to Ava's world and save
Marta from the apocalypse before Magnus
and Francisca do he's able to do this in
dramatic fashion grabbing her at the
last second and taking her to June 21st
1986 that's the day the passage was
first open and when Adam and Ava's
worlds were created as mentioned the
original world tan house created a time
machine trying to prevent a car crash
which kills his family in that process
he splits time and that creates their
worlds yonus tells marta that there will
be a bridge between all three worlds for
a short period of time as the passage is
being created they can use that to
travel to the origin world on
day of the car-crash to prevent it from
happening they're transported from the
cave onto the bridge and thus there's a
new parallel reality to recap in the
first reality Martha saves the onus and
takes him into her world in the second
bartosh stops her from saving him and he
goes into the basement and in this
reality Adam intervenes and they travel
to the origin world and one reality
yonas is killed when he's still a young
man and the other Martha is killed when
she's pregnant with their son in the
third they work together and they go to
the origin world the bridge sort of
looks like walking through space and
they get separated at first in that time
they see childhood versions of each
other who can also see them it's an
interesting way to show their connection
and that each of the child's parents
can't see what they see
after that they come back together and
are able to make it into the origin
world they transport right in front of
the car which then has to stop they
talked Hann houses son into turning
around which stops the crash from
happening even though we didn't spend
much time in the origin world I thought
they did a pretty good job of setting
things up with the family there's
tension but all the son really needs is
a push to go back the other way and we
could tell that tan house would have
felt terrible about it if that's the way
it ended because he kind of wants to say
something and he can't find the words so
I think that part makes sense after
talking to Eunice and Martha the family
does return to 10 houses shop he never
needs to make the time machine so the
two worlds we've seen Adams and Abbas
wind ins are never created technically
they don't really die they cease to
exist
since they never existed in tan houses
world in the first place since time
travel is never developed they just
don't exist
anywhere anymore before that happens
they tell each other that they saw their
childhood versions when they were on the
bridge they think about what that might
mean because they really don't know
what's gonna happen after they fix
things Marta says do you think any of us
could remain or is that what we are a
dream we never really existed Jonas has
no idea what's going to happen either
but it's fitting that he
eles heard the same thing he told her on
the beats the last time he thought he
was going to be erased from existence
we're a perfect match never believe
anything else they hold hands they start
to disappear we see Adam and Ava do the
same in the air at lux room per layer we
see stranger Jonas disappear holding the
pendant stranger marta in the bunker in
the desert and i think it largely works
everything comes full circle
that isn't the end of the episode though
we get a glimpse of the origin world in
what would be present-day i suppose
there's a dinner party going on in
attendance
we have familiar characters whose family
names could very well be different we
see catarina peter bernadette AKA Benny
Regina Torben who is getting over an eye
injury and a pregnant Hannah at first
glance this is an interesting bunch and
it's fascinating when it hits you that
these are all people who were not caught
up in the looping parts of the family
tree that existed because a time travel
we can guess the characters like old
rake charlotte elizabeth and so on would
never be born in the origin world it
seems like claudia was right to think
regina wouldn't get cancer in this world
as well and we get one more fake out and
finding out about tormund's eye injury
just to rub it in a bit Waller and
Hannah look to be a couple and we see
the lights flicker and go out as
everyone's talking just in time to
interrupt the explanation for what
happened to his eye it's not clear
what's going on with the lights going
out I mean in the other worlds this was
a sign that someone was travelling it's
possible that this is related to Marta
and yonas transit into this world but
they leave us to guess about that this
hits Hannah the hardest as she stares at
a yellow raincoat in the hall right
after it happens she writes it off as a
deja boo' at first but then tells the
others that this is exactly what she
dreamt last night in that she says the
lights were flickering there was a loud
bang and then suddenly everything was
dark and somehow the world had ended she
goes on to explain that this somehow
felt like a good thing for things to be
over
it all sounds a lot like what happened
to Eunice and Marta and their worlds in
this world Regina owns the house that
was the con walled house in Adam's world
in the Nielson house and Ava's we see a
picture on the wall that shows us that
Claudia married Bernd
dopler in this world and they look like
a happy and loving family in the picture
I was a little surprised when I went and
checked the family tree on the official
website to learn that Bernd was Regina's
father in all of the worlds this wasn't
really a theory since they didn't set
him up as a candidate it turns out to be
important though since if taranta would
have been her father she would have been
connected to the heart of the looping
family tree finding out that he wasn't
makes her existence in this world makes
sense this makes Claudia's motivation to
save her work and has mentioned before
in a way makes her the key to figuring
things out
Regina poses a question to the others if
the world were to end today and you had
one wish what would you wish for
Katarina answers a world without binden
and as they toast that world without
bending the lights come back on Peter
remarks that it looks like vinden
doesn't want to just disappear and that
makes us wonder how everything might be
connected this is all a callback to a
conversation that teenage older akin
Hannah had at the bus stop in season 1
episode 3 the wording is slightly
different but teen Hannah asked him what
he would wish for and he says a world
without Linden this is cool because it
connects the ending of the show to the
beginning and we can ponder how these
realities all influence each other you
could say that even though the giant
knot of endless pain suffering and loss
that was the world's we knew has been
destroyed there are still connections
under the surface we also get a threat
of hope to weave in there when Katarina
asked Hannah if she already has a name
picked out for her unborn child Hannah
responds that she thinks the onus is a
beautiful name this could mean that a
new version of eunice might exist in
this world where things will be very
different so we get an ending to the
suffering and we get some hope the
worlds we knew no longer exists but
everything still seems to be connected
and that's where things are left there
were a ton of
answers to questions along the way as
well we find out that the trio are
called the unknown and he is the author
of the trinity knot notebook they're
almost always together but we see them
split up to set the accident at the
power plant in motion On June 21st 1986
in both worlds this is responsible for
the yellow barrels and the god particle
/ apocalypses in both worlds that date
is also the same date that tan house
opened the portal for the first time in
the origin world the unknown is the
origin of all the family tree craziness
that we pored over for the last couple
of years in venden he is Jonas and
Martha's son and the father of taranta
with Agnes in both worlds taranta is
Ulrich's father Ulrich is Marta's father
and yonas is grandfather everything
really is connected sylia was Aegon and
Hanna's child she got together with
bartosh and they conceived no and Agnes
so that answers the question of who
their parents were it turns out that
Peter was just a guy whose mother died
and that Boris knee wall came to wind
and on the run from what happened in
Marburg basically just like how they
told us he did no time-travel trickery
for those two if nothing else this story
and ending were well thought out planned
and executed there's a good balance of
answering the pressing issues while
leaving something to the imagination the
music cinematography direction and
acting are all top-of-the-line this is
consistent with previous seasons and I
think it's worth mentioning that Louis
Hoffmann and Lisa Bukhari both took it
up a notch and did a terrific job of
carrying us to the end
I'm sure this ending won't satisfy
everyone but I'm liking it more and more
as I sit with it and am definitely
looking forward to going back to rewatch
without the pressure of having to keep
track of everything season 3 was
incredibly complex but I didn't find it
that difficult to keep track of where or
when or what world we were in I've spent
a lot of time digging deep into the show
though so I'm not sure how this is for a
less obsessed viewer there were a couple
of situations that threw me for a loop
though the tan house origin world sir
but also when stranger yonas didn't know
alt Marta when she arrived in 1888 that
was such a revelation that it was almost
distracting in those first few episodes
to the writers credit though they did go
back and explain those things in a
reasonable amount of time so it didn't
actually ruin the experience and I think
that's as good as any place to bring
this to a close I'm very interested to
hear what you think about the way dark
ended let me know in the comments what
you think if you have any questions on
how things played out I will put out
some more dark videos this week so let
me know if there's anything else you'd
like to see please like this video if
you enjoyed it and subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already thanks
for watching I will talk to you soon